stay tuned to Schoolhouse Rock after
dark movie thinks it can bank some early
negative sins with us by casting a
badass like David Carradine and you know
what movie is right
hey I can't even see the cameraman in
this horn oh wait no there is I totally
can't high school band hates America 25
years into the future Americans have
learned to stop worrying and love the
Nazis in 1975 people believed that mm
air in New York would be even more
sketchy than normal this guy won two
merit badges for fisting reporter
nowhere near the race track is going to
give us the live play-by-play of the
race he obviously can't see how can a
guy be his own buddy also in the future
the only TV station you need is simply
named TV movie rips off the headlights
are eyes gimmick from cars also discount
Speed Racer and this dude gets around he
was definitely a disembodied spirit
looking for his true kill or a minute
ago but now he's actually at the race
discount unborn Justin Long director who
inserted himself into the picture had a
choice
take the blue pin and believe whatever
he wanted to believe or take the red pen
and stay in Wonderland unfortunately he
took both mister president is in his
summer palace in Peking he loves
everybody what is it with futuristic
sci-fi movies and world leaders so
benevolent that they are obviously evil
juice in its wall head this year too
many sins in this one line we had to
break this one out in two parts juice in
its wall head I'm pretty sure that's
sexy but honestly even my penis is
confused what the hell she's talking
about
anyway sexual innuendo aside what was I
thinking again juice it's warhead oh
right a proper response to this would be
yes it does have more juice this year
and you're going to wish your helmet had
a face card also we tried to have more
juice but it failed the nocturnal
emissions test
besides the last time I use the phrase
juice in its warhead I was slapped with
a restraining order only half right hate
to step on a good joke but I prefer to
look at it as half wrong how do you feel
about going into the race with a
navigator you've never met I'd say it's
appropriate since in what kind of a
wacky world would a serious driver like
Frankenstein not want to pick his own
navigator unless it was important to the
plot
Frankenstein is still pushing imaginary
people out of the way also doctor chose
the location of Stanley Kubrick's
nightmares to perform the surgery No
questions he said to the people not
asking any more questions stop mocking
me my fancy sweep her leg I checked out
the car and everything seems perfect
okay whatever you say brand-new
Navigator I've never worked with before
what can I say you have a trustworthy
face an tits I'm trained as a nurse uh
words every man wants a woman to say to
him and be lying while saying it I don't
need a nurse navigator driving a car in
the future has become so complicated
that it requires navigators I see the
machine guns but with this car this dude
should definitely be called giant-ass
knife Joe it's kind of like if
spider-man 3 you could drive a car
discount Sylvester Stallone also I see
The Hunger Games ripped off the
futuristic society's fashion is obsessed
with pink and other bright colors both
from this movie and that's how rocky was
typecast as Rambo forever no one dies
from these bullets so I can only assume
they're blanks in which case why fire at
all I'm eight minutes in and we're still
just introducing the racers wait so it's
the Cobra Kai sensei Rocky Balboa and
came from kung fu in a deadly car race
yep that beats my fanfiction all the
hell spit insult also good to see that
in the future the concept of
aerodynamics has been proven completely
useless eagle-eyed viewers were the
great attention to detail will notice
this train is fakest look even closer in
the background and you'll see the
Jamaican bobsled team finally finishing
the 1988 Olympics none of the reporters
knew where mr. president was when they
were asking Frankenstein about him how
is mr. president
is he still in Moscow but apparently the
TV broadcast did prompt master and
director had an obvious disagreement on
the definition of enough dry ice in the
long and difficult years since the world
crash of 79 holy shit The Hunger Games
is a discount this movie once more I
give you what you want
oh that is the least amount of ceremony
to the start of an auto race in history
they're coming racers take the Lincoln
Tunnel from New York to New Jersey but
end up in a place with mountains
seriously that is the most California
look in New Jersey I have ever seen this
GoPro commercial footage brought to you
by 1975 see this this movie is 28% this
just slightly sped up race footage set
to weird music its way far out man
none of these drivers have the same
favorite route time for any time this
guy needs to make a point he's got
sticks of dynamite lying around just in
case now I know this is bullshit because
these road workers would have waited
until there was a traffic jam to work
today anyone over 75 years old has been
upped to one hundred point futuristic
dystopian society uses the same scoring
system as present-day me this guy isn't
even moving but she still can't ever hit
him
how was she not disqualified immediately
for a Neptune how did she even get into
this race in the first place
oh she finally hit him I guess he
accidentally moved Jesus does the Hunger
Games know how much it ripped off the
running man and does the running man
know how much it ripped off this movie I
have never been more certain of a
character's death than this reporters in
my life there is no way he survives
my only lament is that it won't come
until the final scene and yet none of
the other drivers have seen this on
previous race telecasts and tried to
swoop in and steal Frankenstein's pile
of easy points also some of the nurses
are just fucking with Frankenstein to be
setting up the old people in this way
this is the killing old people with cars
equivalent of picking up a 710 split
meanwhile people are being slaughtered
on our highways but why are they on the
highway on death race day in the first
place don't people that stupid actually
deserve to die also the director must
have said have these people say their
lines from inside some kind of factory
it'll make them look even more
blue-collar also why did they move the
TV between the last shop and this one
they're all in the same outfits the
movie has given us no reason to think
much time has passed but I guess every
10 minutes these blue-collar rebels and
their grandmother moved the TV and
changed the seating arrangement just for
variety
that's racist seen does not contain a
lapdance
Cleopatra has the amazing gift of
looking through binoculars in a speeding
car as if she was standing still ha ha
American Revolution reference cool shot
but you seriously expect me to believe
the resistance built their driver
killing blockade facing the wrong
direction during a One Direction
Transcontinental race
are they five-year-olds what can I say
the MPAA was a far cry in 1975 from the
overzealous proceed bitches we all know
and love today all these cars are being
waxed at the exact same moment all the
damage repair and other maintenance work
on cars was completed at exactly the
same time so the communal waxing could
commence aha they went and got Nero's
wreckage dragged it all the way to the
st. Louis Check Point and put it in its
correct spot in the garage I'm surprised
no one's standing here waxing this thing
right now press corps allowed into the
naked resurfaced on shroom I guess this
is the public naked massage room in a
room this huge and this bright this is a
very useless light and that's it I'm
confused as to whether the people at
home could see the killing or not if
they can't see the race at all then why
would anyone tune in if they can't see
the race then how would they not know
what happened to Nero cheese even sins
do I have to get back for this good
Korman man damn genius put this scene
here where the fuck back in 1975 just to
stymie arson counting efforts random
stalker please the pronoun game so that
Frankenstein has to ask what it means
private rooms as big as a fucking house
still had to take the rub downs in a
group setting for some reason you wanted
to know our route so I told him to go
down 54 through the Cimarron Valley for
dead in why would an experienced death
race or like machine gun Joe not know
that this is a trick or not already know
the details of such a route fun with
your pause button these dummies got
exactly what was coming to them if the
rates announcers suddenly know about
every single kill which they do then
there must be cameras on each car
somehow it's the future I'm fine with
that but then why can Frankenstein Drive
large stretch through the race without
his fake disfigurement mask on without
having his lie revealed to the viewers
despite her suspicions Annie decides to
walk to the other side in front of the
car while it's running and Frankenstein
is behind the wheel the scan was one of
the original founding professors of the
Prometheus school of running away from
things
no time after the speeding racecar isn't
making any noise which is sinful ooh or
else the characters in this car can't
hear it which is simplest bet oh it's my
navigator but he was fixing the car
right I mean how can you just drive off
after like nothing was ever wrong with
the car okay the resistance is now
literally taking their half-assed ambush
plan straight out of the wily coyote
playbook how did this asshole get up
here also how could he tell from up here
that they were coming anyway they went
into a tunnel and that was under another
mountain a geographic formation that
tends to block the view of people trying
to look around it and the wily coyote
plan actually works I bet she holds up a
sign that says gravity lessons as the
dust settles right calamity jane was hot
on the heels of Matilda the Hun so why
wasn't she fooled by the detour
here's stick tire kid who amazingly
survived this year's purge and has once
again playing in the road during a known
death day
how many to go she was totally willing
to walk in front of the car now she
tries to go behind because we need this
tense moment when Frankenstein asked her
to walk around in front why bother to
lie about Matilda's death earlier when
you were just gonna tell the truth later
Franken phallus you know I got just two
words to say about that ball well you're
half right
leave it to David Carradine to interrupt
a good joking rocky pulls his punch
movie thinks that a naked babe is gonna
make me forget the Frankenstein is
banging a navigator he can't trust well
it's right has scored his own mechanics
for 40 points and his off the cats
calamity Jaden Frankenstein is there any
point to the racing aspect of this race
I hadn't once heard anything about who's
arriving at the checkpoints first or who
has the fastest time they're all taking
different routes and so presumably speed
is at least some part of the equation
for who wins this event right because it
seems like only the kill points matter
what see what the fuck does that even
mean do you need to have the fastest
time and the most kills to win confusing
death race is confusing machine gun Joe
is still way ahead on points and he
could win the race even by arriving
second honestly if you want to win this
race you should veer off course and find
as many elementary schools as possible
then worry about finishing the race
after you've racked up a bunch of points
this guy went to the half a school of
camouflaging a mine on a dirt road is
she doing here get back on the road and
try and win the race dead vehicle
graveyard finally tells calamity jane
this is no place to be during a
transcontinental death race Annie gets
distracted by nothing in particular
while Frankenstein openly and obviously
spikes the drink with 1970s roofies also
how many people do you plan on knocking
out in a lifetime with this orgy of
pills there are more knockout pills in
this case then you get M&Ms in one
package about 50 miles wait is this the
same factory where they've had their
base of operations the whole time
because there is no way Frankenstein is
50 miles away from this place remember
back when the rebel leader guy dressed
up as a woman pretended to be a mom on a
picnic and they blew up Cleopatra's
boobs well that was way back in
Pennsylvania now they're in Albuquerque
you are already talking to him asshole
not that I have any fuckin clue how much
it's possible look out he's gonna fly by
you to death is this asshole doing he
just happens to be sitting here in case
Frankenstein got ambushed by rebels
during the middle of the race
the rebels ability to kill drivers is
inversely proportional to the important
characters they might kill the rebels
plan involves having an on greatest
racer in the world drive a car to catch
up to the greatest racer in the world
car crashes and explodes because movies
airplane crashes it explodes because oh
yeah look probably happened also obvious
model airplane his model only the winner
of the race is to shake hands with mr.
president that handshake is all I've
lived for at the beginning of this movie
we were told that Frankenstein won this
race twice he's had two chances to kill
mr. president but sure this is all he's
lived for a hand grenade a grenade in
the hand is worth two in the bush
now you're squealing sound effects go
well with any racing scene even
straight-line driving this grenade
represents Frankenstein's life work to
kill mr. president but sure he just
allows her to take the grenade off his
hand so she can kill a machine gun Joe
worries me is how am I gonna shake hands
with mr. president mr. president the one
who should be worried now yeah totally
wait what where's Annie right now oh no
one notices that Frankenstein's
navigator is nowhere to be found during
all this she just got shot but what the
hell let's have her help Frankenstein
out of his car there are exactly zero
repercussions for assassinating the
president Frankenstein has appointed my
great-grandmother
Thomasina Payne wait great-grandmother
I'm not saying it's impossible but
there's like a 3040 year at between
these two but my press secretary answer
the question stop annoying mr. president
with impertinent questions Junior what
that guy was just asking questions as a
reporter 30 seconds ago and here comes
the reporters death scene one hour in 18
minutes too late
we're abolishing the race because
violence is bad but we also need a good
laugh here at the end of the movie ah
let's just run over one more darling and
have everyone applaud and love it by the
australopithecine history lesson
narrated over closing credits Paul
Bartel you mean the guy who uses New
York's finest taxi service in the usual
suspects that Paul Bartel who knew that
he had done anything else we'd like to
thank Roger Corman for challenging us to
send one of his movies and for that we
give Roger Corman us into
you call me a dirty
[Music]
alright alright bring out the GIMP give
sleeping well guess you just have to go
away come on now won't you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey let him go
[Applause]
[Music]
hear me I am your new president all
citizens will be required to change
they're all aware every half hour
in the movies we just see the important
parts but the truth is a race across
America would include lots of boring
stretches filled with downtime terrible
scenery
eventually you're gonna get tired of
classical and psychedelic or any other
forms of music what do you like to do on
long boring death races across the
continent I'm hoping audible still
around in this dystopian future so that
I can go to audible.com slash cinemasins
and grab some audiobooks then when it's
my turn to drive in the death race I can
listen to cool stories like The Hunger
Games divergent or even the Running Man
nothing makes dystopian future death
competition go by quicker than listening
to stories about dystopian future death
competitions trust me
I'm speaking from experience here
whatever kind of books you like you're
sure to find something among audibles
over 150,000 titles that will make the
cross-country drive go by a little
faster your first book can be free just
by going to audible.com/veritasium